Texas is calling Keynes on the line hey
Kane welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how
you doing Dave better than I deserve
what's up
Merry Christmas merry Christmas to you
sir thank you so I've got a construction
business that I've had past five years
now and I've kind of been normal so I
went and financed every dollar on thing
you could finance I'm in construction I
do paving and so all my equipments
financed and I'm about four hundred
thousand in debt on top of my fifty five
thousand of personal debt which I think
goes hand in hand because the
construction equipment I've had to come
sign on with the business so sure you
know all you know I'm probably about
half a million at that so what's the
business know how much money you're
making in the business this year we've
gross done about 1.1 million 14 that
uh-huh they say that a guardian net on
that what are you paying taxes on um
about 800 Wow a serious margin yeah your
expenses are only 400 grand on a million
- yeah holy Grimm Olli why did you not
pay off everything if you made eight
hundred thousand dollars in one year
well that's the thing we did a couple of
jobs for the same contractor and we're
still waiting on like 400 grand
well 400 grand how much debt what did
you reduce with that
we I produced a couple of trucks that
I've got but I'm kind of waiting to get
the rest of that so I can pay everything
off and I'm sorry well how much are you
sitting on probably about 325 and you're
gonna do what with it if the other check
doesn't come in well I was trying to
figure out what I should apply it to and
and and go from there okay because this
is kind of throwing me off big time and
you know I'm confused on what I should
do you know with this
are you have you got new jobs going that
are cash flowing and you're going to
continue making money while you're
waiting on this other cheque or you're
waiting on this other cheque to survive
kind of sort of kind of had to pull
money from the savings to pay the
vendors and stuffs and and stuff like
that but um do you have nut jobs going
currently that are making money in the
new year yes right now we're just
wrapping up pretty much all the small
stuff weird jobs been completed a while
you're waiting on the other 400 so in
the last two months you've done more
jobs that are yet more receivables
correct yes really really small stuff
though okay what do you usually make in
here and what do you think you're going
to make next year well I'm hoping to
make some more we've got some bigger
wall coming out that's not guaranteed
yet but we've been told we're going to
be awarded the bit so we're probably
slated to make 1.5 with you I would say
good good all right so well what I'm
going to do is hold some retained
earnings in your business it's different
than home okay but not much in this case
I might hold a hundred okay okay and
that's just sitting there just for
survival just so you don't get into
trouble all that kind of stuff and the
rest of it are throwing at that and
these are all personal debts you sign
for every one of them so you just list
them smallest to largest and start
working your way through them but dude
if you make 800 grand in a year and your
total debt is 400 you ought to be dead
free right right confused on how to you
know allocate that know allocated
towards the dead on yeah right I mean
because jump from you know two hundred
thousand a year to one point one you
know we kind of oh okay yeah well and
yeah you know I don't know what your
probability hitting that again then is
if you don't get these two other two big
contracts what are you gonna have you're
gonna be back to 200 grand right I'm
gonna sure would be good to be debt-free
going back yeah that would be that would
be good I mean it's just uh you know I'd
like to be debt-free all around you know
and pay off your student loans and
everything what I mean you got you got
three hundred twenty thousand dollars
sitting there pay off everything but the
equipment today okay set a hundred aside
and put the rest of it towards some of
the equipment in the business and then
when this next check comes in be
debt-free
okay you see how that's working yeah and
then you're gonna be cash flowing like a
bandit every little job then makes money
because you don't have any bills anymore
man except payroll I know I'm excited
okay make sure you're getting a good P&L
going make sure you're watching your
numbers here don't don't be a guy that
knows how to do paving and doesn't know
how to run a business get in there and
learn how to run the business run the
numbers run the numbers you're asking
the right kinds of questions here learn
to stay on top of your numbers cash
flows what'll kill you in the
construction business you got to stay
ready for the cash flow vines good
question it sounds like you got some got
this thing on the run I'm proud of you
to get after it